se conocieron las declaraciones de
impuestos del expresidente de Estados
Unidos Donald Trump el congreso público
casi 6.000 páginas con los datos de
entre 2015 y 2020 El Magnate minimizó la
importancia de la publicación diciendo
que contiene poca y muy compleja
información
el gobierno de izquierda de chile
indultó a 12 personas condenadas por las
protestas de 2019 así como a uno de los
miembros más reconocidos del grupo
armado que combatió a la dictadura
militar de Augusto pinochet
parlamentarios opositores rechazan la
medida
Brasil inició hoy tres días de luto
nacional por la muerte de Pelé en los
edificios más icónicos del país le
rinden un homenaje al que ha sido
considerado como el mejor futbolista de
la historia la FIFA también se despidió
del delantero y hubo tributos en varios
países del mundo
iniciamos un nuevo resumen Informativo
en Francia 24 los acompaña Daniela
blantón después de años de una batalla
legal un comité de la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos que
Investiga a Donald Trump publicó el
equivalente a seis años de declaraciones
Fiscales del expresidente son casi seis
mil páginas con los datos contributivos
de Trump su esposa melania y sus
empresas entre 2015 y 2020 el informe se
conoce a pocos días de que los
republicanos tomen el control de la
cámara baja de Estados Unidos y podría
arrojar luz sobre la riqueza de Trump el
desempeño de sus negocios y las formas
en que según sus opositores redujo
drásticamente o eliminó su obligación
fiscal por varios años el ex mandatario
respondió a través de sus redes sociales
Aunque estas declaraciones de impuestos
contienen relativamente poca información
y no información que casi cualquiera
puede entender son extremadamente
complejas el comportamiento de los
demócratas radicales es una vergüenza
para el congreso de Estados Unidos
vamos ahora a Chile en donde el
presidente de izquierda Gabriel borich
concedió un indulto a 12 manifestantes
que habían sido condenados por las
protestas sociales de 2019 también hizo
lo propio con uno de los miembros del
grupo armado frente patriótico Manuel
Rodríguez que luchó contra La dictadura
militar de Augusto pinochet En las
décadas del 70 al 90 previamente nuestra
corresponsal en Santiago Patricia Luna
nos contó que originó esta decisión y
sus primeras reacciones
el presidente Gabriel Boris cumplió este
viernes con una de sus más antiguas y
también polémicas
promesas de campaña al finalmente
indultó a 12
personas condenadas por
delitos vinculados al estallido social
en una decisión muy polémica sobre todo
por los sectores de la derecha del país
que han criticado la medida como
inaceptable y preocupante y han tomado
medidas como retirarse de un acuerdo de
seguridad que se estaba negociando entre
todos los partidos del país en este
momento además también se amenaza con
poder llegar incluso a solicitar la
dimisión de la ministra de Justicia o
llegar incluso a acusaciones
constitucionales fue una medida por otro
lado acogida de forma muy favorable por
la asociación Nacional de presos de la
revuelta por los familiares que venían
luchando desde hace bastantes meses para
que el presidente Gabriel boric
cumpliera esta medida que había tratado
de hacer A través de una ley en el
congreso en una de sus primeras tomas de
decisiones en cuanto llegó a la moneda
pero esta ley no prosperó en el congreso
no tuvo los votos necesarios para lograr
la amnistía de una gran parte de todas
las personas envueltas en delitos o en
condenas durante el estallido social al
no hacerlo así se ha recurrido al
indulto que es una facultad del
presidente establecida por una ley que
así lo Norma y se han estudiado caso a
caso para ir dando lo que serían los
primeros de estos 12 indultos a los que
se añade el de Jorge matte Luna y que
podrían ir ampliándose en próximos meses
seguimos en nuestra región de América
Latina para hablar esta vez de Bolivia
en donde habitantes de la región de
Santa Cruz bloquearon vías para
protestar por el arresto de su
gobernador Luis Fernando Camacho quien
fue enviado a prisión preventiva por
cuatro meses en La Paz Camacho es un
opositor acusado de liderar las
protestas de 2019 que terminaron con el
derrocamiento de Evo Morales también fue
una de las caras visibles de las más
recientes manifestaciones contra el
gobierno de Luis Arce que se prolongaron
durante más de un mes
y vamos a Brasil porque el estadio
maracaná se iluminó de dorado y el
Cristo Redentor se tiñó con los colores
de la verde amarela para rendirle un
homenaje a Pelé quien falleció él
falleció el jueves a sus 82 años por un
cáncer de colon en todos los rincones
del mundo despiden al considerado mejor
futbolista del mundo mientras que Brasil
inició hoy tres días de luto nacional el
velorio de Pelé tendrá lugar este lunes
dos de enero en el estadio de Vila
belmiro de Santos el equipo que lo
descubrió en sus inicios como futbolista
hasta allí será trasladado en la
madrugada del lunes para iniciar a
partir de las diez de la mañana a las
honras fúnebres que se prolongarán hasta
la misma hora del martes también se
conoció que el entierro será en el
Memorial el necrópolis ecuménico en una
ceremonia reservada a sus familiares
Brasil y el mundo siguen despidiendo al
rey
Lamento la muerte del Rey Pelé ayer
en mi primer mandato como congresista
cuando inicié en 1991 tuvo el placer de
conversar con él unos minutos
una persona sencilla todos lo saben
pero que llevo el nombre de Brasil a los
cuatro rincones del mundo
hoy el mundo entero yo era la muerte de
Pelé y lo lloramos Aquí también
el legado después de muchos años sigue
ahí todavía estamos hablando de él como
si todavía estuviéramos hablando de una
buena película o un buen libro es porque
era muy bueno y vamos a seguir hablando
de este país pero de política porque se
prepara para la toma de posesión de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva el próximo domingo
primero de enero después de completar su
gabinete el líder progresista anunció el
nombramiento del senador Jean Paul
prates como presidente de petrobras por
su parte el presidente del ejercicio el
derecho está Yahir bolsonaro levantó la
prohibición de ingreso al país de altos
funcionarios venezolanos vigente desde
2019 con lo que se permite la asistencia
del presidente de izquierda Nicolás
Maduro a la ceremonia en la que se
espera la presencia de al menos 19 jefes
de estado incluido el rey de España en
lo que podría ser su última alocución
como jefe de estado bolsonaro también
rechazó los actos de violencia de sus
seguidores Como por ejemplo el de un
hombre que quería detonar un explosivo
en Brasilia y dijo haberse inspirado en
el presidente Para hacerse a un arsenal
de armas
Estados Unidos expresó su preocupación
por las relaciones cada vez más
estrechas entre Rusia y China un Vocero
del departamento de estado advirtió que
habrá consecuencias si Beijing le
entrega ayuda militar a Moscú para la
guerra la advertencia vino después de
que el presidente de Rusia Vladimir
Putin y su homólogo
chino se reunieran hoy en
videoconferencia y acordarán fortalecer
su cooperación estratégica Samuel
Salgado nos cuenta más
las mejores de la historia así calificó
el presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin
las relaciones con china en una
videoconferencia con su homólogo chino
Putin afirmó compartir la visión de
transformación del panorama geopolítico
que tiene China
en el contexto de creciente extensiones
geopolíticas la importancia de la
asociación estratégica ruso china como
factor estabilizador
a la que calificó como difícil y nada
inequívoca y dijo estar listo para
fortalecer los lazos comerciales con
Moscú estamos listos para construir una
cooperación estratégica con Rusia
brindarnos oportunidades de desarrollo
ser socios globales En beneficio de los
pueblos de nuestros países y en aras de
la estabilidad alrededor del mundo
para Putin la cooperación debe
fortalecerse también en el ámbito
militar sin embargo
se muestra cauteloso a pesar de que
china no se ha sumado a las sanciones
internacionales contra Rusia por la
guerra en Ucrania insta por una solución
negociada en el conflicto desde el
inicio de la invasión rusa Ucrania el 24
de febrero Putin ha acelerado su giro
hacia Oriente para evadir las duras
sanciones económicas que Estados Unidos
y la Unión Europea han impuesto al
kremlin Rusia ha aumentado casi un 400%
su comercio internacional con dos
gigantes asiáticos India y China con
este último los intercambios superaron
los 9 mil millones de dólares este año y
Rusia se convirtió en el segundo
proveedor de gas en China unas
relaciones bilaterales que deberían
consolidarse con una esperada visita a
estado de She a Moscú en la primavera de
de esta manera terminamos este resumen
informativo con las noticias más
relevantes del día a nivel internacional
pero los invitamos a que se queden
conectados con nosotros en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]